from the makers of
is all you need and do we really need
and is it even useful now comes
enough so today we're going to look at
reward is enough by david silver
satinder singh doynaprecop and richard s
sutton this paper is a more
philosophical
paper i feel though it presents itself
as having practical advice
in it and the core hypothesis
in this paper and it they stated as a
hypothesis
is that maximizing
reward in an sufficiently complex
environment is a sufficient condition
for intelligence to arise implicitly
in service of maximizing that reward
so the the example they give is like a
squirrel who wants to get as many nuts
as
possible has to learn to do all kinds of
things
in the environment in order to do that
it needs to
know how to perceive how to motor
act in the world it needs to understand
maybe the cycles
of the year it needs to be able to
communicate
and fend away other squirrels and so on
so a lot of these abilities naturally
arise
from something that just wants to
maximize a reward in a complex
environment
i do have my troubles with this
hypothesis
right here especially how they present
it
but we'll go through the paper look at
the hypothesis
at the reasoning and as always tell me
what you
think about this work the conclusion of
the work
is that if this is correct this sort of
gives a
straight path to general intelligence
namely
let's just maximize reward in a
sufficiently complex
environment um yeah
and as always if you do like it share it
out
subscribe if you haven't and we'll dive
into the paper
so the abstract says in this article we
hypothesize that
intelligence and its associated
abilities
can be understood as observing the
maximization
of reward accordingly reward is enough
to drive
behavior that exhibits abilities studied
in natural and artificial intelligence
including knowledge learning perception
social intelligence
language generalization and imitation
this is in contrast to the view that
specialized
problem formulations are needed for each
ability based on other signals
or objectives furthermore we suggest
that agents learn through trial and
error experience
to maximize reward could learn behavior
that exhibits most if not all of these
abilities
so it's agents that learn through trial
and error and therefore that powerful
reinforcement learning agents could
constitute a solution to artificial
general intelligence now this has sort
of
this is kind of the deep mind ethos
right in a nutshell
it is let's just build a not like
mo the most powerful reward maximization
agents specifically
through reinforcement learning that we
can
and that will sort of get us to general
intelligence because
in order to achieve anything in the
world
you need to be intelligent if you want
to achieve it
to a very very high degree now
if that tickles you a bit in the wrong
spot
so it does the same to me but um
so they they contrast this here they ask
how does
intelligent intelligence arise
how does it arise and how is it so
bountiful
and so varied and has very
different subsystems and how does this
come about they say one possible answer
is that each ability
arises from the pursuit of a goal that
is designed specifically to elicit
that ability so for example the ability
of social intelligence has often been
framed as the nash equilibrium of a
multi-agent
system and and they go through others
in this paper they say we consider an
alternative hypothesis
that the generic objective of maximizing
reward is enough to drive behavior that
exhibits most
if not all abilities that are studied in
natural and artificial intelligence
so they give an example right here
with the with the squirrel and so one
example
is a squirrel in sort of the natural
world and the other example
is a kitchen robot or a household
robot also in the natural world now
the one of the core points of this paper
is that the environment needs to be
let's say
complex enough and i feel
like they're only going to be satisfied
with
a particular environment then that is
the real world
so um if if they say a complex
environment
just think of the real world like be
that
you know agents on the real internet in
the real world
or be that squirrels in the actual
physical world
they think of environments that are
sufficiently complex
and that's sort of how this hypothesis
draws their power
so the description of this figure
says the reward is enough hypothesis
postulates that intelligence
for example a squirrel acts as to
maximize its consumption of
food that's the at the top right here
um which is the reward depicted by the
acorn the acorn symbol or a kitchen
robot
acts as to maximize cleanliness
to achieve these goals complex behaviors
are required
that exhibit a wide variety of abilities
associated with intelligence okay so the
the squirrel must learn to perceive it
must learn to climb it must learn to
assess the nuts it must learn to bury
them it must learn to
remember where they are and so on and
the the cleanliness robot must learn
also to perceive to use its
sort of movements it must learn to wash
and it might even decide let's get pizza
delivered instead of
instead of cooking because that will be
just cleaner arguable
but um yeah so in in this framework you
can see on the right here
they see all of these different
abilities such as memory
perception planning and so on just
arising
from these things because they say well
in order for the squirrel to maximize
nuts
it needs to be able to do all of these
things otherwise the squirrel will just
sort of die it it can't it can't like
without perceiving the knots you can't
go get the nuts
and also the cleanliness robot if it is
actually good at maximizing its reward
it needs to develop all these abilities
including right like the social
abilities in order to
get a pizza delivered or in order to
work together with the human
maybe even to manipulate the human to
make less
dirt so that's the
that's essentially the hypothesis right
here
they do give some example
um so
they i mean this first part the
introduction i mean you can read it for
yourself but they uh they say
they give these examples here they say
um watching this through the lens of
reward maximization
may in fact provide a deeper
understanding since it explain
why such ability arises for example
avoidance of crocodiles because you need
you don't want to be eaten
in contrast when each ability is
understood as the solution
on to its own specialized goals the why
question is sidestepped in order to
focus upon
the what the ability does um
singular goal may provide a broader
understanding and
it might even lead to new sort of
new forms of intelligence they give
examples of course here the games of
go and chess where just maximizing the
reward
alpha zero was able to come up with
very new very new tactics very new
openings and games and so on and
we didn't teach it to do openings we
didn't teach it to do
uh board control and whatnot or whatever
they call in
the things in go we just asked it to
maximize reward
and it came up with all of these sort of
sub abilities
by itself right
now they formalize this here the
reinforcement learning problem
they formalize it as an agent
interacting with the environment so here
the agent is just the decision making
process
so in the squirrel actually only the the
squirrel brain would be the agent and
the squirrel body is
already part of the environment also if
you're in a sort of
multi-agent system all the other agents
are part of the environment in this
framework and the environment
uh you interact with it and you get a
reward
signal right a reward signal and then
maximizing that reward signal that is
what you call
reward maximization and the core
hypothesis of this paper as i already
said
right here is the reward is enough
hypothesis
and the hypothesis itself says
intelligence and its associated
abilities
can be understood as subserving the
maximization of reward
by an agent acting in its environment
the the it's a bit better stated above i
think that they say
that the main different forms of
intelligence can be understood as
observing the maximization of reward and
that the many abilities associated with
each
each form of intelligence may rise
implicitly from the pursuit
of those rewards taken to its limit we
hypothesize that
all intelligence and associated
abilities may be understood in this
manner now they do strengthen
it they do strengthen this hypothesis
because what you might be thinking of
what i was thinking of first
is that oh you know you can just
formulate any goal
as reward and that's what they say here
they say the reward hypothesis which is
different
from their hypothesis speculates that
all goals of interest in studying
natural or building artificial agents
may be represented by rewards this
should not be confused with
our reward is enough hypothesis which
considers the abilities that arise from
the pursuit
of any such any one such goal
okay so it's different than just saying
well you can learn to perceive by doing
reinforcement learning or well you can
learn to
acquire knowledge by reinforcement
learning now this is stronger
this says that
the hypothesis here is intended to be
much stronger
that intelligence and associate
abilities will implicitly arise
in the service of maximizing one of many
possible reward signals
corresponding to the many pragmatic
goals towards
which natural or artificial intelligence
may be directed
so their idea is that there is a world
and that world is sort of complex enough
right
maybe there's a tree and no you know
there's a
house so there's humans in it and you
have your little
squirrel whatever here squirrel
has a bushy tail and a head i don't i
don't know how a squirrel looks
just this is a head um and
given in this environment you pick
any reward you can think of like any any
reward signal
and then maximize such as like how many
how much hunger do you have you get that
as a negative reward
and then maximizing that reward will
lead
implicitly to the squirrel having to
develop
intelligence having to develop
perception having to develop the
acquisition of knowledge and even
interacting with other squirrels or
the humans in this world
this is a strong hypothesis
and as i said i do have my problems with
it
first though they go through a bunch of
things they say
well let's explore how
we let's explore some abilities that
people
naturally associate with intelligence
and let's explore
how they might arise implicitly from
reward maximization okay so again think
of the
the squirrel wanting to get as many nuts
as possible
or like i don't know a human wanting to
survive and live and thrive in the real
world
how something like intelligence may
arise
just as a product of maximizing that
reward
and so here they go over a bunch of them
the first one is
knowledge and learning and the the
arguments made here
are always they're always pretty simple
they're
they're giving you an example and saying
well in order to maximize your reward
in the real world it's useful to have
knowledge and also because
you don't have infinite memory or
whatnot it's useful to learn
things and to to abstract things right
to to
gather knowledge and so on
and then when you hear when they go for
perception they say well in order to
maximize your reward to thrive you need
to perceive
okay so you know naturally it's it's
like almost a tautology okay
so they say well a reward maximization
agent uh can reward maximize better
if it perceives rather than if it
doesn't perceive
okay so it's it's it's sort of and
social intelligence yes so if you're a
human
you want to thrive in the world it's
better if you are socially intelligent
in fact it's better if you know language
because
you can maximize reward by communicating
so language if if you know might just be
a byproduct of reward maximization
generalization well it's better if you
generalize
and imitation yes it's better if you
imitate
general intelligence well if you want to
reward maximize you need to be
able to instant sort of switch around
between different sub goals
in order to reward maximize and sort of
solve new problems really easily that
would be really good
in order for you to maximize your reward
and therefore general intelligence
is might be you know if an if
if an agent maximizes its reward general
intelligence will help
and i hope you've seen a little bit
the trend here uh through all of these
things and
i think especially in the last thing
in this general intelligence the
the flaw here what i think is the flaw
becomes rather
obvious because i mean
so reward is enough for for general
intelligence
essentially you're saying well
if we build something that's intelligent
right
then um we have then intelligence is a
byproduct of that
so if if you if you postulate your
reward maximization
as being intelligent then yes
intelligence
arises as a by-product their
their whole notion here is that if you
have this complex environment
and you want to do anything you need to
be intelligent and that's how they see
the environment itself
the big question here is of course what
is this environment and what is the
reward
and they have a discussion at the end
where they say
well as long as the environment is
complex enough we don't
actually care right if it's complex
enough you know that
any and and and also for the reward like
any reward signal any goal will do
you can and they say well what if you're
if your goal is to collect pebbles um
in the real world okay so you know there
is a pebble
there is a pebble there is a pebble so
one agent might just
learn to collect pebbles but the other
agent
might learn to sort of use the internet
and buy pebble collectors off of amazon
and then launch a political campaign and
influence all the humans
to also collect pebbles for itself and
then influence
everything and get rich and buy more
pebbles and
that would necessitate intelligence so
just maximizing getting pebbles would
sort of lead to intelligence
and i'm i follow this way
but you know uh again this is
sort of saying if you're intelligent
then you're intelligent
and on the other hand what if
a agent could simply chemically
transform anything it finds into pebbles
or anything that's even possible
there's this this meme right with the
distribution
where um here is the new guy
so here here you have like here we have
this guy with this hair
and uh with the teeth and this goes
collect collect pebbles
and then here you have the i don't know
here's the smart person usually
and this person is like well influence
all the people and buy things with money
and do this and do that and do this and
do that
and over here i just imagine the the zen
so there's usually the the person in the
hoodie right
the zen person well that's a terrible
hoodie
the zen person again going collect
pebbles like you you don't know this
it's i think this is such a this is such
it's just kind of looking out at the
world and
then abstracting that into what they
consider
a reward of the environment
and then naturally tautologically what
will arise is that if you
sort of maximize that then intelligence
will arise
and that's not even the end of it right
because
a lot of things such as survival in the
world and
thriving in different environments are
done without
intelligence if you think of bacteria
for example
bacteria so i don't know so here's the
world and there's like a tiny sliver
where humans can live in about one
fourth or so of that sliver
yet bacteria they're everywhere
okay they thrive much more than humans
so if the
if the goal is survival and fitness i
mean bacteria solve that problem
completely without any intelligence okay
so
i disagree that just reward maximization
is enough
but then these people would say well the
environment is not the same the
environment for a bacteria is not the
same
as for a human like if you are a human
clearly
your approach cannot be to just
replicate so if you're a bacteria you
know here is
here your bacteria what do you do you
simply split
cool don't need intelligence can
colonize the entire planet
however if you're a human that is not an
option if you're a human
you need to be intelligent right your
environment is different
so your environment is much more what
they would say complex
though i disagree i think the bacteria's
environment is incredibly complex
but the human environment they would say
is so complex
you as a human need intelligence in
order to thrive that
environment now again there is a fallacy
here in my opinion right in my
opinion what do i know this is rich
sutton but in my opinion there is a
fallacy here
namely so there is the environment right
and um you're you're the human
right here you're in the environment and
in order to maximize your reward as a
human because you can't split because
there are other humans around
you need intelligence right intelligence
needs to be right here in the human
in order to survive and thrive in the
human environment
however that environment only
exists because there is already
intelligence right so first of all you
as a human
you don't acquire intelligence because
you need it in your environment
you have it built into you you you do a
bit of fine-tuning during your life but
not
like the no one doubts that
a that intelligence is present
even in a baby okay like it it might not
be able to uh to act it out
but the all of the ingredients
like the the learning the the ability to
absorb knowledge and so on
that like the ability to perceive and to
to learn language that is all present
already
so i disagree that humans uh
acquire and have to acquire intelligence
in order to thrive
now they people would say well evolution
uh the evolutionary pressure on humans
required intelligence and that might be
true
but the individual human only needs
intelligence because
intelligence is already present in the
environment
or if you want to call it differently so
here
is your world and you can go into
different niches
right and one of the niches is the
bacteria niche where you simply
you simply split okay another niche
another environmental niche is the niche
where in fact you need
intelligence in order to survive but
that is determined that is just this
niche
right and you need intelligence because
the other humans have intelligence
and because you were you're only
born as a human because you're
because the the environment has
or the evolutionary direction has pushed
you
into that direction so it is not
that the maximization of any reward be
that
fitness has led to intelligence because
the maximization of that same reward has
also
not led to intelligence it's simply that
intelligence is present
in this particular niche of the uh
evolutionary process right i see this as
a clear distinction like i feel humans
first of all they have innate
intelligence and second of all
the intelli the environment is only such
that intelligence is necessary
because other humans before you also had
intelligence nowhere in this process
is the environment determinist or
the driver of the development of
intelligence because
at the beginning right here
the environment wasn't such that
intelligence was necessary
okay so the environments and the
intelligence they
it evolved together they're sorry they
re the environment that requires
intelligence
and the intelligent beings evolved
together
at no point did you have an environment
that required intelligence because of
maximization of reward
and you had an object in that
environment
not having intelligence and then having
to acquire it
it's simply one niche and there are
other niches that don't require it
uh so that's that's that's my one of the
largest
things that i criticize right here
i disagree that reward maximization
is enough for intelligence because
clearly
the same reward maximization wasn't
enough in
other cases also i think that
there is no such like if they think of
the real world
and agents with intelligence in it those
agents only
exist because intelligence exists not
the other way
around the agents don't make
intelligence they
already are intelligent for the most
part okay and
the last thing right here is i just want
to point you
here that reward is enough for knowledge
and
learning okay so now they call learning
one of these abilities that is
associated with intelligence
and now we go to the next part and the
next
part is where they ask themselves well
given that we postulate that maximizing
reward might be enough
for intelligence uh how should we
achieve that
so the the hypothesis
of maximization of reward is fully
agnostic to the nature
of the agent itself this leaves open the
important question on how to construct
an agent that maximizes reward so that
that's the question right
how do you construct an agent that
maximizes reward
until now we've heard no of course the
answer is going to be reinforcement
learning
but until now we have actually not heard
much of that except
in examples so they still leave it open
how you would achieve such an
agent but now they're going to say
reinforcement learning
but first they say in this section we
suggest that this question may also
lord may also be largely answered by
reward maximization
now i don't i don't actually know
whether it is intended here but
right how to construct an agent that
maximizes reward
is largely answered by reward
maximization
huh like
is this intended like is this an
intended back reference saying like
how do we construct x well x
like is this i'm not sure
is this an intended like a a little bit
of a slight of
like a little bit of a joke or something
i'm not sure i'm not sure
i might just be too dumb right
uh specifically we consider agents with
the general ability to
learn how to maximize the reward from
their ongoing experience of
interacting with the environment such
agents we will refer to
as reinforcement learning agents
provides several advantages
so here they go into you know if you you
don't want to
pre-program like you don't want to have
the designer's knowledge of the
environment
uh be in there because the designer
doesn't know everything
you want to actually let the agents
learn themselves and
if the environment is sufficiently
complex
and these in the reinforcement learning
agent is sufficiently powerful
then it will like the richness of
experience of a complex environment will
provide enough signal
for the agent you know disregard its
practical implementation and sample
complexity
technically the whole ex the whole
richness of experience
will provide enough of a signal to
learn all of this but i don't know did
you
there's another thing right here um we
consider agents
with a general ability to learn how to
maximize reward
so how do we build reward maximization
agents which if successful will give
rise to intelligence
right um well by learning
okay however learning up here
learning is a product of intelligence or
an ability that comes with intelligence
right
so like we need we need
learning in
like learning comes with intel learning
is one of the abilities that indicates
intelligence so a little bit it's like
learning
gens so intelligence if something is
intelligent
right it then then it will learn but
also
in order to achieve this intelligence
through reward
maximization that's how we achieve
intelligence
but then in order to do reward
maximization
we need a learning algorithm but if the
learning algorithm is not yet
intelligent right then how is this
happening
so if you can i guess you can make a
split and saying well this
learning that we we use for reward
maximization
that's sort of a learning that we design
or something like this
but even if we design it intelligence
gives
like if we design the learning algorithm
that's
again this this way in a sneaky backdoor
way
or you can say well the type of learning
for the reward maximization
is a different one than the learning we
mean here here we mean the
acquisition of knowledge but i'm pretty
sure the
acquisition of knowledge is part of
reward maximization so
a little bit of a closed loop there
honestly um
yeah so
i'm i'm not i'm not sure but here they
make the case and
of course like i agree with all of this
i agree that rl
you know reward maximization if you have
a powerful enough algorithm it will sort
of discover these sub
tasks and it will has to acquire these
abilities and so on it might not be
super sample efficient
and certainly it's a better way to
general in
to general in intelligence
than like supervised learning
or or just prediction itself
like future prediction and so on
that is and that online learning is
better than offline learning
i agree with all of this right
and here in the discussion by the way
they also say which environment
right and then they say well it can be
any as long as it's i guess
complex enough which reward signal and
here they also they give this this
pebble
example uh where they say well even a
simple
goal in the complex environment can can
give rise or will give rise
to intelligence and
yeah so i agree with most of it but this
this core
the core thing um i'm just very
skeptical about and my last comment here
is that
they they so presuppose
that this reward exists right they so
presuppose that there is an environment
that gives you
a reward and um
i also disagree with that right
so if you look at the only process that
we know
that actually has produced artificial or
not artificial uh natural general
intelligence or
at least human-like intelligence is
evolution the evolutionary process has
given rise to
all the intelligence that we see be that
in
humans or other animals uh
today or or even like social systems
if you consider them to be intelligent
corporations
the evolutionary process is the main
backbone of this and even though you can
maybe formulate the evolutionary process
as maximizing
fitness i don't like there is no
for evolution there is i don't think
that's a good way of
framing it it's rather that there is an
absence
of reward and
it is not a single reward that's given
right
that the the reward creates itself as
evolution goes into a new niche
and uh it is not a
a you can consider it in the abstract as
a reward maximization algorithm if you
consider
fitness to be your reward but i do
i do in my mind there is a difference
between this
and what these people have in mind right
here
of giving rise to social or to
intelligence
in that i would consider the
evolutionary method to have
no reward in the sense that they
describe it right here
and um yeah so
that is to me the the last sort of the
kind of more baseline flaw
in this paper in that it assumes that
there
even is such a thing as a reward in the
environment where
i'm absolutely not sure that this is
even the case
and the only example that we have of
general
or at least good intelligence or
human-like intelligence however you want
to call it
is a process that arguably has no
reward and um it just does what works
and some of the stuff that works
is intelligent but other stuff with the
exact same
apparent reward signal is absolutely not
intelligent and that leads me to believe
to say no
i don't think reward is as you say
enough but that's my opinion please
give me your opinion in the comments i
still read the comments
um and i will do so in the future so
if you're watching this in 2040
and if you're an ai then um
please write in the comment did you did
you just use reward or
did you use something else i'd i'd be
very interested
also please please spare me uh
yeah i'll see you next time if i'm still
here bye